[Music]
any conflicts of interest board member
the mandible sports club so for the
grant application and conflict of
interest
thank you
right I'm a committee member of the
mandible bowling club right
the current register of interests
somebody moved that we receive the
current registry of interest for
information Nikki thank you so you can
act right thank you
any discussion all in favor mean d-did
you insane
ocean please I've got here that I'm a
partner of the Oxford faint but but we
will be closing that down shortly so
I'll just have my name taken off the one
we've finalized oh okay
thank you anything else yeah I'm I just
emailed Thea and over the weekend just
to say I completely forgot about that
I'm the chairperson of the octave
community trusts but show me change okay
thank you
all in favour of receiving that against
Kerry thank you
moving on to the confirmation of minutes
minutes of the Oxford IQ community board
from the fourth match somebody move that
they be accepted as for a record place
Thomas knew you and Shirley thank you
all in favor against carried thank you
matters are
rising from the manners and was just
wondering if we had any update from some
of the things that were talked about
like the speed limit concerns and the
Oaks reserve and one thing that we
haven't heard back from a in a while as
the Canterbury landscapes development
and how that's going with the fire
management plan because I'm sure the
residents we came to see something
before summer rolls around again but I'm
yeah that was the only ones I had purely
just about the walking and cycling
strategy did a member of the Oxford
promotions be included in the group of
people I've got no information on any of
those here Thank You mr. chairperson yes
in terms of the report that served in
front of Council there was a member
included of the Oxford promotion group
in regards to the Yonkers ooh are you
talking about New York's reserve and the
the the potential gold Park Reserve I
believe that there was a submission
which was performed by the board to the
annual plan and staffs response I
believe was that we would continue to
work with the Oxford I work a community
board on a more detailed concept plan
and bring that back to the council as
part of the long-term plan for
consideration for funding thank you
in sorry mr. chip is in terms of country
landscape unfortunately I have no
feedback but I will make sure that the
members get feedback by the end of the
week I'll speak to Matt and just follow
that up for you all right thank you
moving on there are no deputations or
presentations and we've gotten you to in
business but moving on to the
application today okay off the lair
community boards discretionary grant
yeah one from the delicious Charitable
Trusts take this - from the ludus
Charitable Trusts one or the other in
one from the mailable Sports Club and
one from Oxford Alpine Taekwondo
incorporated is really
on these Wilfred grant to the grant
applications through you mr. chairperson
I want to remind people who in June we
the board school has a considerable
amount of funding lift if they wish to
allocate you financially it ends at the
end of June so this is the last a month
if they want to allocate that money I
have requested information from the
finance department if they will be
carrying the funding over they have not
come back to me yet with that regard I
just wish to point out in terms of the
Valdez charitable trust they apply to
all the community board member committee
board two of the community boards have
already turned down the trust for
various reasons yes and then also in
terms of the type 2 I can go Club the
application they were going to have the
South Island Championships this year but
unfortunately it was postponed but they
will be hosting that the championship
next year so that will still need the
uniforms for next year's South Island
championship and the mandible bowling
club applications will straight forward
and the men will cap one as well thank
you okay anybody want to discuss any of
those just wondering how you're going to
deal with them because if you do them on
mess I'm not sure how ray and I can be
involved in but we have the right to
vote on the other ones outside our
conflict of interest just wondering if
you clarify how you would like to deal
with the applications not are quite
happy to
them individually and probably the best
way to do it because of your conflicts
of interest
thank you the first one that failed us
Charitable Trusts it's like just a new
organization that's coming as its
because we've already got a why why
suicide the that runs are not in the way
my career sir can you just help me cross
can you yes I can
we've received applications by this
trust to each of the boards I asked
history who many as their community
turned to do some investigation and to
the trust to find out whether or not
they were currently in connection with
why suicide and why Mackin idiom with
our suicide prevention network she says
that she hasn't been able to contact
them she's tried and also never know
Tina's trial also the chair of the
suicide prevention network has also
attempted to contact the trust and the
researchers on each of every messages
and haven't received information back
from the information that they've
gathered on the Facebook page they don't
believe that they are connected to the
network that we currently have in the
woma Kennedy district end the
recommendation from Tessa is that we
wouldn't provide them the funding stage
thank you Chris thank you I notice that
they're actually based and metal two in
the North Island and they're really got
no connections with the North Canterbury
I believe we are serviced well enough
and in this and I would I would not vote
for it then just
negging alright um just a quick question
do we do we know why the other two
community boards decided to decline here
Kirsten you know I'm not I wasn't at
those meetings but the information which
has been provided at the moment is that
we would be a test essentially and would
be one of two places that we're looking
to trial what it is that they provide
and we have a current suicide prevention
network in a network of social service
providers and our district which is well
connected into a reasonably good job at
the moment suicide prevention is I'm
something which has to be done right
there's a lot of risk in providing a
service and suicide prevention which
isn't aligned with best practice and and
we're not currently aware of whether or
not what is being on offer here is
actually following this practice and
suicide prevention so there are some
risks around providing funding for it
and in North Canterbury so I'm not
answering your question but I'm giving
you some more background the answer to
the question is exactly like I said
they felt that there was not enough
information available on the programs
that the trust will be implementing and
they would also felt that they were
enough organizations within the ymax
district to actually deal with suicide
prevention there is the two main reasons
why they decided to not grant the
funding I did do a little bit of
research on them and found their
Facebook page and also obviously whether
their application and and I have
reservations as well whilst it's a lofty
goal that you know it's a worthy thing
that they're trying to do just like has
already been said here I feel that we
already are well served by what we have
here in the district now that is well
connected with our community services
team
and reading through their application I
find it a little bit confusing as to how
they they wish to go about achieving
their goals so being that they're not
based here at all they're based in the
Manoa to and that you know we're just
going over ground that we already have I
I'm probably inclined to not discipline
sizer in spite of the fact that it's
such a really thing to do but yeah okay
having got the information we've had to
me like to make it emotional is what we
do here Oh Mac sorry given the feeling
around the room I was actually kind of
move the motion that they declined the
request funding this organization a
little second back right thank you
more on favor against carry thank you
moving on to the Mandeville sports club
in
discussion or questions or layman
Shirley thank you I'm just questioning I
think it's a great idea to hit for the
sports club to have it we've got a lot
of these machines and Waimakariri so how
do they actually fund their batteries in
their pads and that that's my question
Oh Beamer for windy can clean D can
answer there this is why they've come to
us because they they don't have an only
bad job to do so they thought that they
thought that when they got them from Red
Cross the Red Cross would come and renew
them but that's not the case at all and
everybody would be all in the same boat
they'd have this I would imagine there's
a bit of a game isn't it we do have some
in our community facilities as well and
the ones in our community facilities we
pay for the cost of changing the
batteries and though so we have someone
in the rain gear town hall is an example
and I think we have one in this building
in our libraries as well so we look
after the cost there of course the
Mandeville sports club it's their own
building and they leased the site and
responsible for that one particularly
they get a ground for maintenance but
the ground for maintenance doesn't cost
and doesn't cover in this case the AED
which I've got was in the club can I
just ask
who the question in Kris could it be
incorporated in the accustomed future
rather than having to come to the board
for funding I think it's a great idea
and it's not a lot but it seems that
every four years they're going to have
to ask for funding to do the batteries
and the pants the men of all sports club
do come to council on an annual basis
and ask for additional money to make the
costs that they have for maintaining men
of all sports fields for the community
and they have come as part of this
ending plan and every renewal plan since
I've been here they do leased the site
themselves though and there are some
things which the council doesn't provide
costs for and those are generally sports
club rooms which sports clubs have for
themselves and we're there it's not a
building which is looked after by
counsel this we don't provide the
funding for the AEDs inside those
buildings as well so I don't know of
other AEDs I could go on the F and have
a look for you but there will be others
and other community facilities which are
owned and operated by community groups
and they are responsible for getting
funding for that so they may come back
here and ask for funding in the future
but they may also go to other funds
other community external funding
providers and ask them as well so right
any
further Thomas this might be a probably
more a question for windy or mark but
they're asking for 620 where are they
getting the extra $200 for the request
that they need to fund it and would
enough cause our maximum amounts only
$500 would it have an impact on them if
they only received $500 from us I think
probably that they would would manage it
and in their budget round it's just I
can't eat because I we haven't been to a
meeting lately but since Cove 19 the
supply has dried up as well but I'm sure
that they were probably maybe I'll -
well I'll have to do that because you've
got to have it going I think in the epic
a
States they've got Turner dollar
sponsorship for another group and the
application windage rights and since the
the Cova 19 hat I mean the the main
source of income that the club gets is
through its parent restaurant and then
dried up substantially and the club is
working through a strategic plan which
is in terms of perverts marketing and
probably long to in sponsorship
activities that might be covered down
the track anything I would add and as
that remember this is available the
whole Mandeville community it's not
inside the club room is actually on the
outside of the building so it's
available for the entire community to
use 24/7 as one three-year mr. Jefferson
I would just want to remind the
courtroom is that 500 is just a guide so
if you wish to give them the whole 620
you are allowed to do that 500 is not a
limit placed on the board it's just the
usual amount to guide the board I was
just gonna say flea really I be happy to
put a motion to that everyone's happy
would be that we support the full amount
of funding for what they're asked for do
I need to go reason why no it's
I like the comment that during last year
we gave two or possibly three amounts of
money which were over five hundred so
it's not that we can't do it
okay so just regarding this application
Chris did say just before that he
doesn't know how many we have in the
district and I do kind of get the
feeling that the question that's on the
top of people's minds is well if we
grant this well everybody else come at
us well actually I don't think there are
that many AEDs in our ward and if
Mandeville came back to us every four
years I don't see that as a problem it's
an additional source of funding for them
they serve a huge portion of our
community and pretty much just about
everybody that lives in Mandeville
Swannanoa Hoka area and further afield
probably makes a trip there at least
once a week 40 years or 40 weeks of the
year so I have absolutely no problem in
supporting this and also um Thomas I was
just doing the math there if they've
received a 200 other grant elsewhere
that the cost for the pads and the
batteries exclusive of GST does come up
to six hundred and twenty dollars so
that's what the math all went Stoke
so I have absolutely no problem in
supporting this and I hope you will too
Thank You Nikki take a very all in favor
of that motion against it's carried
thank you to remove
to the Oxford Alpine Taekwondo
corporated application is there any
discussion on that in their application
they actually asked for funding for the
uniforms but then they also said that it
could be also used for equipment that
they may need so I'm just wondering what
they're actually going to be spending
the money on I would make the comment
that most martial arts clubs the
participants provide their own uniforms
not on the father any further
do we actually know when they say
uniform are they talking about geese
because that's what usually is provided
by the individual are they talking about
like a tracksuit or something or does
anybody know looking at the what they've
done for premium and peril which is here
and they are tracked paints with
branding and hoodies with branding and
tea shoot with branding so I mean it's
quite it's about 3,000 something rather
so they're only wanting a smaller pump
for it yeah yeah which end and just
thinking back a lot of time said I know
that the Oxford knit ballclub what used
to get uniforms are nothing to how you
can do things like that so it's not not
a new thing that and I think in the
application they mentioned that there's
a national tournament about to happen in
Oxford which is going to be very big I
guess but for the area and I think their
application for funding goes some way to
at least have the club members looking
like a looking like a team worthy of
hosting a national event Thomas does you
surely as I've said I am concerned
because their work their wording says
they haven't decided whether it be for
uniforms or other equipment that they
need to purchase so I think we need to
any recommendation actually mention it
should be for uniforms is there any
requirement for them to
say if they don't receive the full
amount of funding for the uniforms will
it just subsidize the uniforms or will
they use it for something else maybe I
found an answer there I think if we
request then it has to be used for that
then that is what the hefty year is up
for if they don't use it then they do
have to pay it back it's as simple as
that right Thomas you awaken to the
emotion yeah I may be to move that we
give them five hundred dollars for to be
spent on club uniforms thank you sure
all in favor against Jerry thank you
yeah we move on to the the man of a
bowling club is there any discussion on
that one this club works very hard to
improve the the property think they do a
lot of work they're very proactive group
they it's not very often that I ever see
them coming and looking for anything
that most of it they they do themselves
so they're very proactive group
am i able to say something no yeah the
the mandible Bowling Club is actively
trying to promote the the sport in the
districts only one of two bowling clubs
that are in our ward and find it very
difficult given that there is no school
for a start off that's associated with
the bowling club they do hold two to
three times a year
invitations to people in the district to
come and have a go at the sport of warm
balls they do have a number of bowls
already that have been donated over over
many many decades and the thought was to
try and encourage more members to come
along and play they'd need to have more
modern bowls and so then they're looking
at upgrading their back up collection of
bowls they do have a large number of
tournaments and will be the most popular
every year is the the ladies tournament
and it's very difficult to actually get
into that particular tournament because
it's always well and truly
oversubscribed mostly by christchurch
city bowling members who just love
coming out into the countryside and
we're only seven minutes away from the
from the border if you like and so it's
a it's an area that's becoming
well-liked by all the neighboring
bowling clubs as well and we're just
looking at trying to help in the
proposed promotion of the sport thank
you for
information right here on a sunny off
icon that's a very close relationship
with woody in Bowling Club in New Year
seven eighths go once you've read to my
thing they might rotate whether it's yes
even he writes and they go and do
bowling and I have a little in-house
competition so maybe the men double
bowling club may be worth him
approaching a hooker Swannanoa and
schools to see if they would like to
start out such a thing to they may eat
some yeah almost funding I think burn
through that song but really great
initiative from wind
right
I'd put a motion on that oh sorry no I'd
like to move the motion that we accept
the replication the full amount of
funding level
Sara
thank you all those in favor against
hear it thank you
moving on to the elephant of the board's
submission to the lawmakers District
Council's in your plan
again I was running mr. cheat with you
and give the board a bit of that day to
have our submission wheat than what the
response was Jean Lee the feeling really
insights that you gained from the
submission the inside I gained was soon
the I've had no feedback and I have no
idea but it was very awkward doing it on
doing I can't tell you I guess the
question was asking was that the
council's asked many questions of you
from the board in terms of ear
submission was that you just talking and
them just nodding and moving on to
things presented we were your question
on anything on any particular part of
their submission people are honest with
you I found remember there were some
questions but not very many
I don't have the the minutes of the
actual meeting where the where it was
presented and I'm not
I only know off the top of my head what
the response was in relation to the Oaks
reserve but you will receive responses
reasonably soon from the council
regarding your submission okay
so Shirley can you comment on the
barbecue for Ashley Gorge yes I can
sorry I just couldn't remember all of
the different points in different
submissions I believe that the response
was that it would be appropriate for
their ashley gorge reserve advisory
group to work with the Oxford community
board to look for funding through the
general landscape and budget so you
would expect that they will be coming to
this board now I'm seeking funding
through the general landscaping budget
for a barbecue we actually put the
submission in and I understand that
there are barbecues and other reserves
and the council is actually paid for
them so why should they actually gorge
one be different we have lots and lots
and lots of reserves throughout the
district and the council supply as a
limited number of barbecues and for
those reserves we've had requests in the
past for barbecues to be put in various
reserves and the council hasn't provided
funding for those we at the moment are
looking at our budgets in terms of the
effects of Cove of 19 in what capital
items that we can spend to enhance those
reserves and it was felt by the council
appropriate to ask the board to look for
funding through their own general
education budget as opposed
to providing extra funding for a
barbecue in Ashley called reserve
haven't we relinquish down landscaping
budget I believe you've relinquished the
landscaping budget for the next
financial year but you've carried over
the existing landscaping budget which
you haven't actually spent a huge amount
of so you've got the current year's
landscaping budget which will be carried
over into next financial year and as you
have lived in it is thirteen thousand
four hundred and ninety dollars we and
because the AMEX reserve dog park is
gonna look into the long-term plan we're
not going to be needing to take money
out of our landscaping budget to fund
there I mean it produce a tricky one the
board identified nine thousand dollars I
believe towards doing something with a
net reserve I think the original
proposal went to the last long-term plan
and it didn't make it in the last
long-term plan and the board Dean
allocated nine thousand or something
along those lines towards trying to
create something which is beautiful
Walker's to be able to walk their dogs
within that reserve but didn't go as far
as actually creating a dog park within
that reserve I understand that the board
is still looking for something a little
bit more they're still wanting a dog
park and that reserve the cost of a dog
park and that reserve is going to be a
hundred thousand plus between a hundred
and two thousand one hundred and two
hundred thousand dollars so if the
council's going to look seriously of
providing that as part of his long-term
plan then the board's general
landscaping budget won't be sufficient
to be able to do that so it's likely
that the council would have to supply
funding outside of the general landscape
and budget and the general landscaping
budget would then be available again the
board
could choose to do something
intermediate but it's already been
considered I guess and considered there
extra funding for something more
substantial from the council is required
or eat it oh sorry oh yes Chris do we
have an update on the commendable
village car parking situation and if the
landscaping associated with the car
packing that was proposed earlier this
year do we have a plan of such a
landscape so the same question was
actually asked by cancel the mailings as
part of the new clean process as well I
was actually surprised that it wasn't
done to be fair I think before covered
19 hit there was plans in place to go
down and actually put the ball ads in
and complete the work which was
identified that got put on hold and
grant MacLeod who's the green space
manager has got there on his agenda
again to make sure that it happens
quickly
thank you just about the West West
reserve toilets that were proposed what
was in the budget then it wasn't and it
sounds like you'd like to actually put
it back in I think we actually need a
robust discussion about that because
there's at the right place to put toilet
with no potable water and the sewer
surge has to be sucked out and etc so I
really think it needs to be closely
looked at because it's going to cost a
lot of money in the future to service
area so the money was in the budget and
the money was I can't recall exactly 125
yeah and that was actually only part
funding so we were looking at getting
money through the tourism infrastructure
fund and round four as an application to
part fun there which was a Memphis
stretch fund didn't put out the around
four they closed round four because of
Kovach 19 and therefore we weren't able
to get their additional funding so we've
actually pushed out their funding not
into next year but into the year
following and to the
21:22 financial year but we have
indicated to council there if the
tourism infrastructure funding becomes
available again we will be coming back
to Council and asking for money to be
brought forward to take advantage of
their external funding in terms of
providing toilets in areas like that and
we've done one recently using tourism
infrastructure funding that saltwater
Creek on maintenance Road it doesn't
have power it doesn't have water and it
has a sewage getting sucked out similar
to what we'd be proposing it a twist
oxford reserve it's been very successful
the cost of sucking out is relatively
small and based on the fact that we have
a number of toilets with their system
which we have a contract for right
throughout the district another example
would be Pegasus Beach toilet which has
water but no power and also two teams
need to get sucked down as well in some
of the other ones which you would
actually think would be connected to
mains have a two tank system which
sometimes requires to be sucked in high
use times as well so the cost is
actually relatively small in terms of
servicing those toilets and if we can
leverage the government for some funding
through the tourism infrastructure fund
we believe that that's a sensible thing
to do and it was identified as part of
our toilet facilities public toilets
strategy which we presented as part of
the last long to play a named consultant
with the boards on at time
I have my hand raised but it's probably
a good opportunity to ask is it not more
appropriate will we have the report sent
through probably in time for our next
meeting
from the annual planned deliberations
because I'm looking at the at the
submissions and officer's comments thing
in and diligent here and I know we've
made a few changes in those along the
way so it probably isn't really
appropriate to comment on them at the
moment but I would imagine that the
results of our submission will be put
through so we can read next next month
and then we won't be guessing three you
mr. chairperson yes after the annual
plan is approved and I think the 15th of
June or the 16th of June we will get a
letter on our submission answering the
council response to our submission and
that will go into the July agenda of the
community board and for the community
water consider just comment on the
Ashley gorgeo it's my understanding that
even if the board decided to commit all
its funding to a barbecue we still
couldn't afford that we were I'm the
best record advisory representative and
they're around understanding that's sort
of like a 20 thousand dollar project but
yeah and we only have 13 so I don't know
how that works but sorry I you're all
looking at me but it wasn't a question
it was a comment I guess I can comment
back the the HD good reserved advisory
group are extremely good at fundraising
they have done in the past and shown
that they're really good in that space
and if the board was inclined to give
them a portion of this general
landscaping budget they could use that
towards as a contribution towards the
funding for a barbecue and the reserve
and look to do external fundraising as
well so you're right it's not likely to
cover the full cost but it would be a
contribution to get them along the way
right we've had the motion we vote on
favor that we ratify here board
submission to the in your plane will
favor needs carried thank you there we
are on to our than 7.3 ratification of
the bad submission to the draft in your
plan and I haven't carried straps on
your plane and somebody
that we ratify that submission please
right thank you
singing uh Thomas in his discussion
goodness
okay well I'm tell you that yes
Gary thank you may be on to
correspondence is it no correspondence G
persons report I've got three items here
presented submission to the draft in
your plane the chance will be a zoom by
attended to North Canterbury
neighborhood support meetings nothing
much really happened and outside of that
I've spent a lot of time contacting
members of a private club that I belong
to bi-weekly phone course during the
lock is just to keep them informed
because we had him meetings once a month
that's it from me at this point made us
for information ten point one team point
thirteen point three somebody move that
we received those items Shirley windy
will in favor hints carrot Thank You
members information exchange
okay can we somebody move that we
receive the chairpersons report please
mean anything you making wrong favor
against Kerry thank you
now we'll move on to members information
exchange
it's not a memo Thank You mr. chair as
advised to other members and our zoom
ketchup I think I will update you on the
outcome of the we stood in some Hill
Road let's come back now to council
staff and the points wrote people for
the time being my only other activity
has been with the mandible Sports Club
ten is one of their meetings recently I
probably think the major output from
that meeting was a funding for Stage
three of the tragic plane in decline so
the board's kind of fun Stage three
itself and the board members are just
providing feedback on stage one and two
to go back to the author of the report
and they got to meet with the board of
the probably I think at the next meeting
we will press on at stage three and try
and get a final draft report for
consideration any of my usual committees
have been running at the stage so that
one thing I have been doing a bit of
work on as the EM proposal or erode and
I've done quite a bit of looking into
that and have been talking to windy and
also to eek in and it seems to be is my
time to talk about this in general that
is not it seems to be a proposal that is
coming and and very fragmented way so
there's Tory's it was consents that have
already been issued from ek n which are
historical so they probably from about
2014 for the ability to change the
waterway and access the water it's why
met irrigation limited that is providing
the water for the dam so those concerns
have already been given the consent met
and
being locked in at the moment as the
consent to put the dam on top of an
aquifer which seems to be that they've
been able took the boxes that it hasn't
I don't think there's been past is yet
but it sounds like it's probably going
to be past
from what I could hear from the lady
that was doing the consider a key and I
think if this had been put forward as a
proposal all at once
it may not have got through but because
it's so fragmented and but so that have
already been approved and it's also
under ezel's consent from way more
irrigation limited as to what is
happening with the water on that farm
and any ramifications of this or any
environmental concerns that it may cause
under Weimar irrigation limited resource
consents so there's no resource consent
specific to this actual dam that has
would provide any information of what
impact it may have on any ground water
or waterways in the area and then the
council then has consents by the way may
accounts all for the hazard control
illness disability but causing a flood a
first breached the information and the
report is quiet minimal for that it's a
breach on a sunny day and a breach on
the eastern side sorry on the western
side of the dam so all in very favorable
locations and conditions for a breach
rather than looking at the worst-case
scenario and I think that the Chancellor
obviously are very aware of that and the
engineers will be asking more questions
about that and also are the consent for
the earthworks obviously the cats was
above ground and so I from what I can
gather though the council was asking for
more information from the people that
applying for the resource consent that
because of the whole situation and the
hair of the project actually has been
brought to the table it's and so many
different pieces and so many different
parts that the whole projects itself is
ability being looked at and in has been
classed as a minor so it will won't be
publicly notified so there's quite a few
issues I think in the process I mean it
very well could be a great project in a
in something that does Peter for
environment but who knows because no
information is provided and and the
other thing that I had that sort of ring
to me is because the resource consents
and projects like this can go to the
council and go to eg and and II can can
pass all these resources since before we
even get to hear about it through
getting knowledge from there is lesson
the council would even grew one like to
be and involved in oh it would like to
be and the email contact list for
receiving he can emails because it
sounds like they would be more than
willing to put us on the email list to
receive the Ariza was consents so if
there I just wanted to make sure
everyone wanted to be involved in there
and if that's the case I can ring up the
lady who made the number for and talk to
her about it and just see if we can be
added to the outgoing mail of the
resource consent and then we can pick up
on things like this project if it if it
came through and maybe about it through
something before it's too late so I
guess my question is is there anyone
there would object to being on their
email list once everyone's happy to be
honest I can just give up obviously our
bulk email and some yeah I haven't heard
anything more back I sent in their email
that you all received through the chair
until you sitting it on I have a
feedback from anyone about their at the
stage
see I've got a question is this on
flatland and I guess you could say yes
it's flatland it since one at Olin so
it's um just up just so it's on North
erode probe up five K's up from the
tremor an intersection yeah that's where
it's locators so any lens or where
sloping towards the sea so any ground
water or any contamination is going to
be downloaded that India from them and
pretty much the very end boundary of
farms of where your lifestyle box will
start so there are an awful lot of
private wells downstream of the
irrigation areas
another question I wrote is how high are
the walls of this overall upon rather
than the dam it's not anything like the
Waimea irrigation it's dim what they're
proposing I think that it's still a an
extremely large amount of water it's a
hundred and they see something thousand
cubic meters of water that it holds and
I think it's three meters high the Dame
but higher and so alright thank you for
that have your own surely thank you I
attended the waymaker Access Group in
March they some of them were concerned
about the new signage law because
there's a lack of monitoring from the
from the council staff and there's still
a lot of challenges on footpaths for the
disabled people that can't see very well
etc they're concerned that the new
businesses aren't getting requirements
of what what is actually needed as far
as the discipline disabled etc in the
Cairo riverbank steps were actually
one mentioned and I know when I went on
that boat ride they were hard to
actually see because I do have a sight
problem and we were told there a
scooters were to be introduced and and
ringing were so I don't know if there's
going to be a new clause in the bylaw
that I'm sure they look cow from roading
staff advised us that Ness the national
speed limits are going to be looked at
and so that is really about the Main
Street in Oxford but whether that's
going to be a long time or not I tended
the draft in your plane thing at first
choice and Wendy will say that we I
think we had about three people that
actually came and actually spoke about
the district plan yeah and I did listen
to your submission and I thought you did
quite well for the drafting so that's
fine yeah I actually got contacted by
one of the people of Oxford regarding
the assessable streets regularly preach
regulatory package so I read through
that and actually did a personal
submission because the you know though
they will allow cycles cyclists and you
know II scooters and all sorts of things
on on footpaths and the future I don't
know we irregular will be but no noise
warning devices and they can speed up to
fifteen kilometers an hour and so that
is the reason why you actually got the
council's submission to that and
regulatory package and I thought the
council did a very good submission on
that I did listen to some of the
deliberations and the audio was
absolutely shocking for the where you
couldn't hear it was but what I'm
concerned about us you didn't finish the
deliberations till the 27th and there's
a media release
at 4 o'clock the day before bed
management I'd say on the council yeah
and I also contacted the group said I'm
involved with Buell Advisory Group and
evidently that's in recess that's what
they said I don't know but there's a
couple of matters and I we have been out
and I don't know whether it comes under
the landscaping budget or not but the
three trees did along the front of the
reserve and inside the fence and they
would like that you know these two
members would like those replaced if
they can so whether it comes out of our
landscape or well I don't know and and
also when they have think you know Pony
Club things here the water tank is not
big enough and it's quite a small tank
there's not enough water to flush the
toilets executor wins a few people there
so I don't know either
let needs to be looked at Pearson Park
Advisory Group they're old fences still
up and I don't know with the current
environment of trying to save money
health and safety why can't a club or
something
remove that and get a bit of funding for
it rather than pay big dollars and
regarding the composting site and
Division Road there are still smells
coming out of it but the only person who
smells them as the nearest house but
they are keeping a record of all of
those there's lots of trucks coming and
going but they believe that it as the
mature compost coming out of it thank
you thank you sure
I've been fairly quiet under lockdown
but there's just a couple of things I'd
like to support Sarah with the prospect
of getting results consent
applications sent through from akin and
just a quick question do or does the
Waimakariri District Council will
receive copies of all of those or is it
something that he can would need to be
approached directly
secondly the the the general landscaping
fund could we look at using part of
their for landscaping of the mandible
village car park
and has there been a plan done for the
landscaping of that area I understand
that it's not in the in the annual plan
but perhaps that if there is a plan that
has been done by green spaces could we
look at using part of that for that in
lastly the Oxford main road there were
there was a an email that I received
late today about a national funding for
improving the safety of that is that
something that we can talk about today
or is that on a future agenda is you
talking about the memo that was sent out
this afternoon by Vanessa Tom that I
forward you from Vanessa Thompson we can
I was actually hoping that we can have a
workshop or resume workshop off in a bit
later just to give members a time to
actually read the memo because they'd
wind out about Cora post full this
afternoon about the funding if that is
okay with you mister
you need more answers than that
it's definitely a possibility the green
space budget was going to pay for a
little bit of tree work and in the
entrance into the car park and in the
bollards around the area which was going
to be am identified for car parking
there wasn't any budget to pay for any
additional landscaping which would look
at potential picnic tables and possibly
some gardens in the reserve so those are
the things which the board could look to
put the general landscape and budget
towards if they decided that was where
they want to put their money and we'd be
happy to come back to the board with a
landscape claim which looked at a little
bit extra then they'd be a minimum that
the green space budget was going to
provide if the board would like us to do
that can I just ask wouldn't their
picnic tables talked about um we gladly
go yeah you're right James to tip them
so oh that's wonderful we didn't have
any extra money for any additional
landscaping so if the board would like
us to come back then we'd be happy to do
that can I please just answer the
question please Chris appen Oxford we're
you've done all that work and to buy the
buy the tree and and also going into the
car park in the cafeteria that new
cafeteria though there's nothing being
done there for the gardens so is that
going to be done or because that's
something that we also need to deal with
was just hollow see at the moment you
coming up at you coming out to see me
some stage they look around yeah yeah I
just would like a little bit of
information before the next meeting
place yeah I wasn't aware that they were
empty gardens sitting there now
now is the right time to plant them so
yeah when I come up and see we'll have a
look at those and if we will plant them
straightaway if they're sitting there
look I wasn't wearing it so I'm writing
a list here of things that I need to get
back to various people including
yourself
surely in regards to the trees she said
it died and need to be replaced so we'll
get someone to contact you regarding
those because we do a budget to replace
trees on council reserves which you have
died it's in a replacement budgets so
I'll get someone to contact you about
there specifically as well Thomas just
just a quick question again to Chris
there is a an application and for
resource consent to subdivide the land
on the east side of the man-of-war
village with the intention that the
owner of the mandible village would
purchase that extra bit of land during
this stage is there any opportunity to
be able to have an indication of car
parking or is that is it just to be a
subdivision request from the excellent
current owner I don't know the details
of this sorry um if they they can
subdivide the land and if they want to
use it for the purpose of extending the
village they'd have to get his own
change and if they were to do that
there'd be a public process to go
through but they would also have to
identify an appropriate number of car
parks to service the village in any new
year eeeh that they would develop
there's business and the council would
be looking at that very carefully to
ensure that they were the appropriate
number of car parks to service any new
business Thomas
thanks Doug
I think our area has maintained its
community spirits throughout the whole
lockdown I know everyone that I spoke to
never I was out and about walking
everyone was really cheerful and
optimistic I've been quite busy with the
community trust working with them
they've been running their food bank at
an increased level to normal and they've
also been supplying essential workers
with childcare which has been funded by
orangutans very key so that's there was
quite a bit of heated debate from a few
people a bit aired out the whole process
but it was really it was quite labor
intensive and it was basically meant one
childcare worker to one family for four
weeks basically loving childcare worker
so that was quite a it was quite
time-consuming organising that for Jonah
team and they've also been running their
normal medical transporting services and
as well as consider continuing their
normal community of work just remotely
by the phone I know Joe's been
struggling with just the fact that
everything is on over the phone now and
if you do have a client it's very
difficult to work with them and in the
various services they need but I think
this is going to be a sort of the
environment that were in for a long time
so I think we've a get used to it in
some respects the fresh choice has been
delivering groceries to bottle people in
the community which has been really good
and I know lots of the community is very
thankful for that and I just think in
general most of the people most people
were quite appreciative of measures
taken and I think everyone's start and
they looked back to normal now but what
there was one thing that's been brought
to my attention it's the car the lights
in the gym carpark in Oxford the new
owner of the crews old house now that
the trees of all off the leaves there
are three mess of floodlights and the
carpet which actually shine right into
his bedroom at night
and they ran all night even when the gym
was closed over lockdown so I was
wondering if there's any way we could
have a report on that and if there be
any option to maybe putting a timer on
them so two of them turned off after 10
o'clock and the gym closed or I don't
know it just seems a bit ridiculous that
there will be three humongous fog fog
lights that are running 24/7 but yeah
it's something that we need to look at
in the future like you know any other
then to say they all definitely look
into it the lights have been put there
because of security reasons in the past
we've been asked to put lights and lots
of places around Pearson Park and and in
all of those facilities for security
reasons in the past and there's always a
fine balance between providing security
and also providing nuisance to
residential property so there's lots of
things that can be done in terms of we
can put screens on the lights we can put
timers on the lights and there's things
that we can do so we'll look into it
we don't want le LED lights as well
these days shouldn't they don't have
much in the way of light spill and they
like to know what they're pointing it so
we might be able to change the bulbs as
well so I'll just I'll get that looked
into and make sure that we can do what
we can the best we can do happy to if
you pass on the details of the person
who's affected we're happy to contact
them and talk to them as well
cross just we just probably need to
clarify with the police as well because
I know that those lights were out there
for the reason to pick up car number
plates so just need we just need to make
sure that it's going to because they're
all it areas all been and surveillance
by the police at any rate so just don't
want to what do we do we don't want to
just stop
right councilors really which one goes
first
um well of course the laughs has been
quite different for the last good while
and I've been one of those ones that
have been made to stay home I might add
I've been quite happy about doing that
and I just loved zoom meetings very much
loved them because you could all get all
tied it up and once you've had your
meeting then you can go back and do what
you're doing instead of doing a 30
something rather Kay home drop so it was
great we'll hang around here for another
meeting but any rate so I really
appreciate all the zoom meetings that
we've had it's been very helpful indeed
and I also appreciate and Chris and I'm
saying this to you I really appreciate
the regular context was with the
managers keeping them up to date with
everything that's happened because when
you're at home you actually do lose
track of what's what's happening because
you're not asking about so I very much
appreciate that too we've had two days
with the annual plan that was full on
and a lot of work and of course
unfortunately we haven't been able to do
everything for everybody because we've
had to drop the rates down to 1.5 so
there's a lot of stuff that's not going
to happen this next year and it'll be a
little bit of a catching up process well
for right now we had a right utilities
in rating meeting by zoom and that was
very successful we talked quite quite at
length about the road the Southbrook
road for the walking and cycling and in
Flex and riders and the update of the
road to be done which a lot of people
from your high currents in such like
will be using that part of the road
quite often so it'd be good to get that
tidied up and some places where people
can walk in cycle while I've been
allowed to get out only
but I've traveled around I walk
dachshund and had a good look around at
most things around and like Thomas
it was very nice and pleasant everybody
was talking about it was and good humor
and it was it's a very it was actually a
very tranquil area and and really it was
lovely to see people but unfortunately
we had just one or two people hit
doggies that didn't believe in bringing
up the doggie dooz which is a shame
because a lot of them did and also i've
wind had a lockdown and various roads
now that I'm allowed to be at a bit more
and when it had wards and the Downs Road
when I had look at that because I had
someone come and bring me out about it
next week we've got a road safety
meeting by zoom and then I'm just
wondering if anybody's got anything that
they want me to bring up at Road Safety
you can just let me know around your
area if there's anything anything else I
don't know how many how who's going to
be on the zoom this time but I'm hoping
that they all will come to the beyond
the zoom we've had someone come to the
door today and complaining about boy
races that have been coming around doing
the circuit round from starvation hole
and coming down and Lucas Bay Road is
like that and they just lovely just
thought that and down in its shingle
Road so he had a talk to the police and
the police said to go and see windy so I
will take that to Road Safety and like
which we know we've got another one of
these issues where people decide just to
put a fence somewhere they shouldn't
ought to put a fence and well actually
had legal right what a fence and back
and so that the staffing and a staff are
trying to deal with this particular
person to come to some arrangement that
the post and the middle of a tarsier
road isn't actually really acceptable
but anyway it's on the land
that's us things that people do during
the lockdown yeah yeah I suppose since
the last time we met on zoom' I've just
tried to capture a few items of interest
since the last time we all chatted
without going over old ground but um
yeah it's been a very busy time for for
council with the annual planned
deliberations and whatnot I've also been
involved throughout with the community
teams local welfare committee with my
lifestyle black hat on and yeah we you
know we really have a great team of
people looking after our people and
they've been very very busy and working
very hard I trying to find the page here
but I know there was a hundred and fifty
percent increase of food parcels going
out from the kayakoy food bank but that
said from from kayakoy community support
yeah you know that that said I think
that people in our Ward have fared
pretty well except you know I have I
have spoken to some people that you know
there's anecdotal evidence in a few
areas where there's some more I'd spread
job loss and it's something that you
know we're very concerned about because
the people that are losing their jobs
right now are had never been in this
place before and they don't know how to
access help so I would ask you all to
please keep your ears to the ground for
anybody that you know that finds himself
in that unfamiliar territory so we can
direct them to the safety nets because
they are out there I think that's really
important for us as grassroots people as
a community board that we do listen out
and watch so that we can make sure that
that our folks don't fall between the
cracks we have five new Y Mac youth
council members that have just been
inducted two from Rainier high school
and three from kaya PO one of which is
from a hoka so that's kind of exciting
they're looking forward to getting into
it and and we will be getting some
turning up at our meetings did Thomas is
a very good suggestion I think as you
would all be aware with the annual
planned deliberations we did manage
through a whole lot of scrimping and
saving and cutting and slashing to get
down to 1.5 percent overall which i
think is a really good result for us and
but as we are going through those
deliberations I did pay careful
attention to keep my ear out for for
things that we would think we're
pertinent for instance the well we've
already talked about the points road
scheme which mark has updated you guys
about but the Mandeville drainage
projects the weather field Lane
improvements have been deferred to 2021
so I guess they were supposed to have
been done in the last in 1920 but so
they're on the board for 2021 the
Mandeville resurgence divergent upgrade
stays in 2122 for design with
construction in 2223 and as Chris has
already pointed out the Mandeville
village reserve improvements are which
it should be underway so that's good
news and let's see here the loose deer
that if you guys know about the deer yes
well I finally found out where those
deer belong had a quiet word to our
animal control and have given the guy a
little bit of grace to get the animals
back in and fix the fences otherwise we
know who's door to knock on now after
five months six months of chasing them
out them down so I'm happy about that we
have spoken to a couple constituents
about various concerns which hopefully
have come to some happy endings and
let's see ah and and a pat on the back
for all of the hocus want to know Amanda
ville recycling customers we are the
stars of the recycle bins we've got the
cleanest recycling of the district so
head on the back everybody that's
something that's really important that
people need to make sure that they do
that properly or it's a user to lose a
thing and it saves us it not only saves
us money it saves rate payers money but
it's also good for the environment it's
the right thing to do so keep up the
good work and without boring you all too
much more I think I will leave it at
that
thanks guys right consultation projects
that are then board funding update the
board discretionary grant before
tonight's that's one thousand and fifty
eight dollars and the general
landscaping budget is at thirteen
thousand four hundred and ninety we have
as Chris pointed out elected not to have
landscaping budget amount from next year
but we retained this year and but the
discretionary grant do we keep that over
or do you mean the two thousand dollars
that we've got left over after tonight
hopefully we can carry that over I will
actually confirm that with finance and
report back to the board as soon as I
have answered them but usually it is
carried over yes mr. Chia do you do you
wish us to do I move that that we
request that that landscaping I mean the
budget be held over to the following
year what do we need to do that or do we
not
yeah sure
put the motion three university up isn't
in the at the next board at July at the
beginning of the next financial year
there's usually a report that comes to
the board with the imbalance and to say
if it's going to be carried over or not
carried over that as well as
confirmation of the landscaping grant so
I don't think there's a need at actually
now to move forward to be carried over
thank you just that we do want to make
sure that mistake was it that's only
because we haven't really been handing
it out some because of covert nineteen
that were actually in this situation
because usually we've got everything
spent so and I just think it's really
valuable for our communities if we can
hunger thank you in D major items mr.
chip is now please make a suggestion
that we move this to the end of the
agenda so because this does not get live
streamed so that we can actually finish
the livestream portion of the agenda and
then team to everything that's not half
stream so move on to item 16 is
questions understanding orders they are
ma'am busy general business I understand
the orders are also none and oh you said
next meeting will be renze July the 8th
at 7 p.m. venue to be announced and at
that point I will close the meeting
[Music]
you